[Music]
we've had a lot of criticism of the
Prime Minister's plans they filed this
morning so it's time now to hear the
defense joining us is the brexit
Minister quasi quanta thank you for
being on the show
now to start off with us a lot of
stories in the newspapers this morning
about the possibility of the boat being
delayed is that going to happen my
understanding is that we'll have a vote
on Tuesday and we are looking to win
that vote I mean there's a lot of
speculation lots of people saying lots
of different things but we won't
actually know until the day itself and I
look forward to concluding the debate
and seeing what happens you say you're
looking - absolutely absolutely can you
really look me in the eye and say that
you think there's a possibility that you
might actually win that look in the
House of Commons votes anything can
happen and I think that we've got a good
shot of winning a good shot winning yeah
I think so because the argument is it's
a strong argument I think the deal is a
strong deal I wouldn't have taken up my
post if I didn't believe that the deal
delivers the brexit vote now we heard
Hilary Benn we heard him talk about
business we heard him talk about
uncertainty and that's exactly what
passing the withdrawal agreement the
final vote will do it'll deliver
certainty I was in my constituency on
Friday talking to business people small
businesses and they said to me we need
to get the vote done we need certainty
and they actually looked at me and said
why are you politicians playing silly
games that was the phrase they used
about about the future of this country
they're talking about providing
certainty then what is the plan because
she must have a plan B any responsible
government have a plan B as I said we've
got to try and win the vote I'm not
going to speculate as to what happens
should the deal or the final vote be
voted down I think that would be create
a lot more uncertainty I think it would
create chaos as a word that's been
described I think Tony Benn himself I'm
sorry I'll take that as a Freudian slip
Hilary that himself said on your show
that uncertainty was exactly what
business didn't want and I think the way
to end that uncertainty is to vote for
the deal on Tuesday at the same time
though we've seen around a hundred
conservative
please express their issues which will
deal the dup so they'll vote against the
S&T labor the Lib Dems and the
government became the first government
to lose emotion finding it in contempt
of parliament and these are
extraordinary times
what does trees may need to do to turn
it around and to rescue the negotiation
you're right that there are it is these
are extremely times I think lots of
people are under a lot of stress there
are difficult issues but I would like to
put it in context we were in the EEC and
the EU for 45 years it took us about ten
years to get in in the first place and
we're coming out and what the deal does
what the agreement does is actually
manage that process in an orderly and
smooth way it's a difficult thing to do
is no country has done that and the deal
on offer the withdrawal agreement is a
very good way to manage that exit now I
understand why people who want to stay
in the EU want to tear it down I'm
slightly more confused by brexit ears
like I was I've campaigned very
vigorously for brexit and very surprised
that people on our side of the argument
are when we have three months and three
weeks left to our formal exit our
willing to blow up a deal which actually
offers a very good path out of the EU
well let's talk about one of those
people shall we Boris Johnson is written
in the Sun on Sunday today he says when
he talks to his friends and colleagues
about why they might vote for the deal
they offer a groan of despair and only
give one reason which is because they
believe there's no alternative if we've
run out of time and run out of Road I
mean you're someone who's relatively
close to Boris Johnson I mean I took out
my post a few weeks ago I've spent all
my time almost all my waking hours on
the ritual agreements and I said to
Boris the more I read the agreement the
more I liked it and the more I actually
got into the weeds of it because I think
it delivers on not three but four things
it delivers on freedom of movement we
get to have our own immigration policy
we stopped the annual subscription to
the EU Club if you like after the
initial payments we have our own
independent trade policy v c ju ends its
jurisdiction
over Britain and it's a strong deal from
but there are some issues it's not that
you can see white people have concerns
about being trapped in that stop for
example yeah I absolutely see why people
are concerned about the back stop
because the back stop is not an ideal
situation having said that the back stop
is a contingency so if we haven't ago
she ated a free-trade agreement then the
back stop kicks in I'm confident that we
can organize and sign a free trade
agreement with the EU people say well it
you know it took them seven years to do
with to do a deal with Canada or Korea
or whoever it was but the difference was
that those were third parties we've been
in the EU for 46 years we will have been
in it for 46 years so it should be very
relatively straightforward to conclude a
free trade arrangement in much less time
than would be the case in 3 to
third-party countries we'll be talking
to dominic Rob or were hearing into that
I did earlier with Dominic Rob a little
bit later in the show the former Brett's
a secretary and he said but that
actually was room to negotiate a better
deal when it comes to the backstop that
it could have been a just a temporary
arrangement well I wasn't I wasn't privy
to those discussions and of course he
has his own reasons for why he left
government and why he felt that the
negotiations were unsatisfactory but to
Dominic and other brexit dear colleagues
I would say that we have three months
and less than three weeks before we have
the formal exit Day if the deal goes
through we have a plan with which we can
leave the EU and that's what many of my
constituents are saying they said we
voted to leave and this is a plan that
actually delivers that so you think that
if it doesn't go through
we might not leave the EU well but
clearly people think that because Tony
Blair was in the in the studios last
week saying that we should have a second
referendum and the reason why he wants a
second referendum it's because he wants
to stay in the EU and you just have to
look at things like betting markets for
example there they're saying that the
chances of a second referendum are
increasing because of the uncertainty so
I really implore brexit ear colleagues
to think about what they're doing you
know they will consult their
constituencies and their own conferences
but really I think more uncertainty more
confusion is simply going to could well
frustrate the
and that they want I mean the problem
that you have is that it doesn't seem
like there is a majority for this deal
in the house of comments and if the
Norway plus option and something that
your cabinet colleague am Bharat and has
suggested is a plausible solution it's
staying within the single market and the
customs union accepting premium into
people is that something that you could
stomach I speaking personally I would
not want the Norway plus or whatever
it's called the no way arrangement
because it simply doesn't allow us to
have our own immigration policy and
clearly free move freedom of movement
free movement of people was a big issue
in the referendum campaign which I
supported where I supported the leave
campaign so I don't think Norway plus or
whatever you would like to call it
actually delivers on that so would you
resign if that was the government's
policy then well let's just wait and see
I think that we have to win the vote on
Tuesday and then after that we can see
where we are and another potential Plan
B that people are talking about is they
could have managed No Deal and as I kind
of brexit here your selfie are you
worried about what No Deal would look
like you mentioned a manage no deal I
want to manage deal and that's that's to
me is a better outcome than a managed No
Deal I think no deal is again adding to
uncertainty it's adding to an air of
chaos and what business people are not
just because it's not just business
people it's actually people who work in
small businesses are concerned about is
having some degree of certainty they
want they see it as a soap opera really
a lot of what's going on and they want
the soap opera to end and they want to
get on with their lives okay of course
it caught on thank you very much for
joining us thank you
[Music]
you